It's really a circular pattern.
You have legitimate chemicals made by
American chemical companies
making their way illegally
into the supply chains that
lead to illegal laboratories.
In Colombia they produce cocaine,
in Mexico they produce heroin or meth.
And these narcotics make their way back,
in a circular motion, all the
way back to the United States
and Europe, where they're consumed
at great profit to the cartels.
The subject of American
chemical companies fueling
drug production in Latin America
is a pretty sensitive one,
even though it's been
around for a long time.
When we were investigating
the whole package
of everything that was
happening in this space,
one of the best leads
that I came up with was
a small police unit in Ecuador
that we had never heard of,
and that we had no idea existed,
that gets funding from the U.S. government.
And they were up against an extraordinary
wave of chemicals being
trafficked through Ecuador.
We didn't have any idea that the heart
of what they were up against involved
one of the biggest
deployments of border forces
in Latin America, and sparked
a small war along the border
between Ecuador and Colombia
with this full-time drug lord.
On January 27th 2018, in the
early hours of the morning,
there was a massive explosion
in a town called San Lorenzo.
A stolen Mazda pickup truck
packed with explosives
went off and it just created
a path of destruction
about 1,000 feet in diameter.
You have to understand,
it was the first car
bombing ever in the country
and it was a really shocking event.
In the end there were dozens
of people who were wounded
and the focus of the explosion
was a police station,
the main police station in that town.
The police were completely sure
of who was responsible for this,
and they ended up blaming
a well-known drug
trafficker in the region
and his name was Walter Arizala.
But everybody really knew him
by his nom de guerre, which is El Guacho.
Once the police assigned blame
for this horrible explosion,
they started to ask why?
And that led them back a
few days before the bombing,
when a special police unit in Ecuador
had come upon a massive cache
of specialized chemicals
that are used in the
production of cocaine
and that chemical is
called calcium chloride.
Calcium chloride is kind of a
strange chemical to think of
when you think about cocaine.
It's a very commonly used chemical
for many, many different,
very legitimate things.
For example, melting ice on streets,
keeping dust down on
places like tennis courts.
But in recent years the
chemists that produce cocaine
in Colombia that's
shipped all over the world
found a really good use for this
particular common
chemical, calcium chloride.
To make cocaine requires
many, many different chemicals
and solvents that are used to extract
the key ingredient cocaine
from the coca plant.
These are regulated under
international drug laws,
so they're hard to get.
Cartel chemists can use
calcium chloride to recover
and recycle the heavily
regulated solvents they need.
That means, the chemical gives them
a backdoor for bypassing drug laws.
They can use the even
more important chemicals
over and over again,
without having to find more.
As a result of this being
one of the key chemicals
in the production chain of cocaine,
police in Ecuador and Columbia
have focused intensively
on seizing that chemical,
so that it doesn't get
to the clandestine labs
there in the jungles of Columbia.
Because once you take that
out of the production chain
it makes it a lot harder
to actually produce
the quantities of cocaine
that they need to produce
to fulfill demand around the world.
So the police in Ecuador
formed a special unit
solely dedicated to seizing
drug making chemicals.
That's what they've been doing
so, they've been quite effective.
And despite these massive seizures,
you still had massive volumes
of this getting through,
enough for the cocaine labs to make
huge amounts of cocaine
over the last few years.
One thing that has surprised the police
for these last couple of years
when they've been focusing on seizing,
is they kept seeing the same brand
of calcium chloride
packed in the same bag,
straight from the factory
of the company that made it,
time and time again,
in the back of trucks.
And they called it
Finnish, meaning Finland.
And that's because the
stuff was made in Finland
by this company called Tetra.
Well, the company called
Tetra is actually a company
based in the United States,
just outside Houston.
And it's a major chemical company
and one of the factories
they have is in Finland
and that's where all this
stuff was coming from.
Calcium chloride takes
quite an amazing route
to get to the chemical labs in Colombia.
It starts in Finland at
Tetra's factory there,
where they actually make calcium chloride.
One of the biggest factories in the world.
Then it's shipped all the way to Peru,
to a single company that buys
it in massive quantities.
And then it moves across Peru
to the border of Ecuador,
and is smuggled across the
border, basically in plain sight.
And then it goes by truck all the way up
across Ecuador and into Columbia,
to what is basically the biggest
cocaine producing region in the world.
Tetra is not just in the chemical business
it's in the oil and gas services business
and one of the chemicals
that's really critical
in the oil and gas business
is calcium chloride.
It uses it in fracking and
other fossil fuel operations
and then it has like this
whole other side-business
of selling calcium chloride
in sacks to the food industry,
to the construction industry,
to the road de-icing industry,
to airports, using it
for water purification.
And when the fossil
fuel business goes down
they really rely on these
other industrial sales
to keep their sales up.
So we were trying to
figure out why its sales
of calcium chloride had just
really exploded to Peru,
which was the fountainhead
of all the trafficking
that was happening through
Ecuador and into Columbia
and it was just a single distributor.
We started looking through
their financial statements,
conferences that they did
with investors and analysts
and we found just a basic description
from one of their vice presidents saying
their oil and gas industry
had suffered so much
because just fell into a slump in the U.S.
especially fracking,
and so they were really pushing
sales in every other area
where they could sell calcium
chloride as much as possible.
And that had driven, I think, a 24% boom
in their sales overall globally,
from about 2013 through
2017, at the exact period
that we saw these sales were
really dramatically increasing
to a single importer in Peru.
And so the company's
position was really that
because it wasn't regulated in Peru,
that all of its sales to
Peru were completely legal,
and that they didn't have
anything to worry about.
The irony was, the U.S.
government was paying
this police unit in Ecuador
to drain this elicit pipeline,
while at the same time
a U.S. company was filling
and refilling that
pipeline through Ecuador,
through these booming sales.
And the more they knocked it down,
it just kept coming back up again
because it kept getting refilled
again, and again, and again.
And it seemed, in the end,
like nothing could stop it
if the company wasn't gonna try
to control its sales at all.
Ecuador is in a very strategic
place in the cocaine trade.
It's not a producer of the drug,
or of the supplies that go into it,
but it's strategically placed
between the biggest regions
for producing coca and
transporting cocaine
out of South America, to the
United States especially.
It's really overwhelmed the
country in a lot of ways,
in terms of the violence
that it's brought.
Cartels fight violently
to keep their trade.
At the center of all
this is Walter Arizala,
who's known as El Guacho.
He came to dominate the cocaine trade
in that particular region,
which is the largest coca
producing region in the world
and he was brought up in a very
desperately poor part of Ecuador.
And it was also in the
heart of the civil war
that was going on in Colombia
under a guerrilla
movement called the FARC.
FARC commanders recruited
Arizala as a fighter
when he was just a teenager.
He quickly became very
adept at helping the FARC
manage the cocaine operation
that they had in the area,
which was a key element that was used to
fund the war that they were fighting.
He was a very good
military commander as well,
and he was good at running
a cocaine operation.
So that's how he came to
become the principal drug lord
in that region, and came
to be the protagonist
behind this wave of
violence that came after.
Now a conflict that's
lasted more than 50 years
and cost more than 200,000
lives may be closer to ending.
Colombia's president and the
leader of the FARC rebel group
signed a ceasefire agreement today.
In 2016, the FARC guerrilla group
basically agreed to lay down their arms
and disband in sort of a
peace deal with Columbia.
But Arizala didn't wanna
leave the drug trade
and he took 100 fighters
under his command,
and basically created his own private army
to protect the drug trade in that region.
It basically is one of the largest
cocaine production cartels in the world.
He did that very
successfully for a long time,
until the police in Ecuador and Colombia
started really cracking
down on his operation.
By the end of 2017 they'd arrested a lot
of his top lieutenants, including the man
who basically was responsible
for acquiring the chemicals
he needed for his drug labs.
They were making massive
seizures of chemicals,
especially calcium chloride.
This drug Lord, Arizala, was determined to
regain control over that
region and over his cocaine
and he began actually
chatting via WhatsApp
with the police commanders
in this town of San Lorenzo.
Saying, give me my men back
that you just arrested,
give me my drugs, give me my chemicals,
or there's gonna be trouble.
And so this went on for quite some time
so the police were worried
something was coming,
but in the end they couldn't
do anything to stop it
and that's when the pickup truck exploded.
Which started what became
a war along the border.
That pressure came to a
head towards the end of 2018,
when they essentially cornered Arizala
and some of his men in
Colombia, in the jungle,
and ended up shooting him dead.
They basically had gotten
the most wanted man in
Columbia at that time.
But the drug trade didn't shut down.
Someone stepped in and took control of
the massive cocaine producing
empire that he lorded over.
They kept cranking out the drugs,
which means that their labs kept working,
which means the chemicals kept coming.
And we know this because the
police commanders in Ecuador,
since he got killed, had been seizing
basically regular major shipments
of calcium chloride time and time again.
So even though this chemical
which was being sold by a U.S. company,
was fueling all of this trafficking,
the war on the border, it seemed
like nothing could stop it
and it was all just kind
of this circular trade.
The U.S. paying Ecuadoran
police to drain the pipeline
and a U.S. company refilling
it again, over and over
and despite the irony and the circularity
of what we were seeing in
South America with Tetra
and its product, it
certainly wasn't the only
U.S. chemical company that we found
whose legal sales were being easily tapped
by drug syndicates to
produce the deadliest drugs
that were being sold on
the streets of America.
In the 1980s, there was a
flood of cocaine production
from Latin America into the United States.
An epidemic of crack in New
York is now out of control.
Do you have no words to
describe how bad it is?
The CIA and the Drug
Enforcement Administration
in the U.S. made a rather
embarrassing discovery
that about 95% of the
chemicals that were used
to make cocaine in
South America for the U.S.
all came from American chemical companies.
There's a list called the Red List.
At the very top is a chemical
called acetic anhydride
and it is the only
critical essential chemical
that you need to make heroin
and under international drug laws
it's one of the most highly
controlled of these chemicals
sold anywhere in the world, except Mexico.
I went into this medical supply store
with a Mexican colleague, and
we bought a one liter bottle
of J.T. Baker acetic anhydride
and the seller volunteered to us
that he could easily
get us an 18 liter jug
and with that one 18 liter jug
that you can buy for about $300
you can make about a million
dollars worth of heroin.
The company was able to say
that it did everything perfectly legally.
Having U.S. companies involved in that,
even if it's unknowing, it
just seems extraordinary to us.